let's see the formulae of the three
important trigonometry functions we
consider the same triangle we have seen
before this is the site adjacent to
theta this is the side opposite to theta
and this is our hypotenuse we have seen
the formula of a sine function sine
theta equals opposite divided by the
hypotenuse remember we don't write an e
here then what is the cosine function
equal to the cosine of theta is written
as cos of theta we ignore the i n e the
cosine of theta equals the ratio of the
length of the adjacent side which is
this side to the length of the
hypotenuse cos theta is adjacent by
hypotenuse the third important function
is the tangent function as I said before
the names sound very fancy but the
formulae are very simple the tangent of
theta is written as tan theta and that
equals the ratio of the length of the
side opposite to theta which is this
side to the length of the side adjacent
to theta which is this side but the word
tangent sounds familiar
isn't it a line which meets the circle
at just one point yes that's correct
but we don't see a line or a circle
anywhere in the picture don't worry
about it now you will know why it's
tangent in one of our other videos so
let us review what we just did sine
theta is opposite by hypotenuse cos
theta is adjacent by hypotenuse and
thanne theta is opposite by adjacent
let's play with these formulae let's try
dividing sine theta by cos theta sine
theta is opposite by hypotenuse sine
theta by cos theta also equals sine
theta multiplied by 1 by cos theta 1 by
cos theta is actually the reciprocal of
theta and the reciprocal of cos theta
would be hypotenuse by adjacent so we
multiply this by hypotenuse by adjacent
look at the right hand side can we
reduce it further yes we can cancel out
hypotenuse from the numerator and the
denominator
that gives us opposite by adjacent hang
on does this look familiar
of course it does it's the value of tan
theta we just proved one of the most
important relations in trigonometry sine
theta by cos theta equals tan theta but
how do we remember so many formulae it's
very simple observe the first letters in
each of the cases look at the first
formula s o and H so let's write Soh
here now look at the second formula it's
C a and H so we write CAH here next to
Soh and in the third formula it's T oh
and a we write T or a here what we get
is so cot wah well it may sound funny
but that's the best way to remember the
formulae so got wah so let's review the
formula one last time in this video
assume we have a right triangle
with lens three four and five units
before we find the values of sine cos
and tan let's write up code on top
so cut wah now see how simple it gets
let's find sine theta first it's so sine
is equal to opposite by hypotenuse the
side opposite to theta is three units
long and the hypotenuse is 5 units long
so sine theta will equal three by five
now let's try to find cos theta see the
code it says gaw a and H stand for
adjacent and hypotenuse so cos theta is
adjacent by hypotenuse
the site adjacent to theta is 4 units
long and the hypotenuse is 5 units long
so cos theta equals 4 by 5 which is 0.8
approximately and what about tan theta
ad equals opposite by adjacent opposite
side is 3 units long and adjacent side
is 4 units long
tan theta will equal 3 by 4 this video
was purely formula based to really
understand how the functions vary with
angles do watch our video based on unit
circle